good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday hey
Claude hyd hey Jax how you doing I am
good thank you for asking good morning
everyone hope everyone had a peaceful
weekend we are back on the air we are
excited to get back it was a it was a
necessary few days to just kind of take
a step back and I'm glad that we did it
yeah but I'm excited to be back I'm
excited to be back too we have a lot of
talk a lot to talk about a lot of things
to recap things that you and I both
watched over the past week um I feel
like the past week in this country has
been extremely intense but extremely
necessary and I now like feel waking up
today for the first time I feel like
I've been living like sort of in a
constant state of anxiety much like a
lot of people I'm feeling optimistic I'm
excited to make the changes and do the
things that we say that we're going to
do and I'm just excited for this next
evolution for us and for for the country
yeah and you know what's like it's not
exciting but a positive is that there's
been so much going on in the last week
and it's it's not for nothing like there
have been so many updates in this case
and other cases like Derek Tobin's
charges were up and then the other three
police officers were arrested and
charged they reopened Brianna Taylor's
case like there there are things
happening yeah is good like that is the
point of all of this activism so I think
that that's a good thing yeah changes
are being made it really does feel like
we are in the middle we're witnessing
history do you know what I mean you know
that say I'm like decades happen in like
things don't happen for decades and then
decades happen in days I obviously watch
that saying but that's the gist of it um
that's how I feel about this week like I
feel as though we are a changing country
over the course of this week and and
this shows changing with it yeah and
it's it's been cool to see influencers
and celebrities who don't normally you
know touch on these topics just like
diving headfirst into educating
themselves and
becoming a part of the conversation like
ourselves included um and I feel like
that's a really awesome thing to say
yeah I agree and I feel like I've also
seen a lot of people you know
encouraging others to speak up because
they recognize that people might be
afraid of saying the wrong thing
um yeah which I very much understand but
we just all need a little grace and and
room to grow yeah and I agree it's like
we can't really accomplish anything if
we're so divided and of course this
country feels so divided but I've just
seen a lot of unity like on social media
and just in the world this past week and
that's been like a bright spot in this
dark time yes and you know what another
bright spot is because um the corona
virus pandemic is still waging but New
York City is entering phase one today
which I thought was just construction
but then my newsletter told me that it
was construction and a bit of retail um
and I just I'm finding that's so
exciting like I really feel like it's a
brand new day today yeah that's exciting
I didn't know that phase one was
anything other than like construction
and manufacturing yeah well it's just
it's exciting and I'm looking forward to
the world reopening because it's been so
long like I feel like this week was
really really long but then I forgot
about the three months before that where
we were all quarantine you know it's
like my mind shifted so much from like
worrying about a pandemic
to worrying about systemic racism that I
just forgot like about the things that
happened before you know yes I
completely agree but now everything that
were it's all coming back together but
I'm just I'm ready to do our job you
know I feel like last week we didn't and
we shouldn't have and we just needed to
sit back and listen and absorb
everything that was happening and been
and has been happening but now we are
here to talk about those things the
things that we learned and also bring a
little bit of levity into your lives
because everybody does still need to
have a little bit of a laugh once yeah
belly laugh a belly laugh never hurt
nobody
no no she did not okay well I want to
start to get into a little bit of the
things that we were watching over the
past week we'll recap our toast movie of
the week at the end of the show I'm so
excited to recap the hate you give I
absolutely will also assign our movie
for the end of this week which Jackie
chose and I'm very excited about I'm
very excited about as well um okay but
first Oh so one of the podcasts that I
listened to because we instead of doing
our own podcast we're going to be
listening to other podcasts and so I've
been listening to 16:19 and first of all
it's just so well done like we obviously
like you zoom audio and you know kind of
hack to shuck and jive but listening to
a podcast with like crisp audio and
music and all of these different
elements and you know bringing in like
historical recordings it's just it's it
was a pleasure to listen to on an audio
level and just as like a podcast person
that is important so I was listening to
code-switch like a bunch of episodes
this week and I had this same experience
like not only do they add musical
elements and like they tapped into old
interviews from NPR it was much more
like I'm used to listening to podcasts
that are conversational and they're like
about reality TV and the people are
always talking over each other like
that's my genre but Coates which was
like so it was like storytelling they
were really painting a picture with all
the elements and I agree like it was a
totally different genre and it was like
really well done yeah it was a pleasure
to listen to and also the content it was
you know a historical retelling of the
establishment of this country the
beginning of the slave trade and just
everything that has happened throughout
American history in the lens of that and
it was very interesting listen I would
encourage you guys to listen to it I
think one of the most eye-opening it but
also enjoyable episodes was the episode
about American music and how like
American music got it sound that
separated it from European music or what
people had been listening to and um it
was that minstrel uh choral chorus music
and that was inspired by but really
ripped off from
the music of plantation workers and just
oh yeah hearing everything through that
lens it just makes you realize and the
episode started off really interesting
it was about a guy he was cooking
meanit's kitchen his friend was like
let's listen to Yacht rock have you ever
heard of that mm-hmm
it's Yacht rock I didn't know that was
on right I guess it's like music that
you listen to and you're on a yacht
that's what I assumed it was
that's what Sutton's track was trying to
tell Kyle at its yacht we're like that's
a genre so he was listening to this
Yacht rock right exactly Yacht rock
while he was cooking and he was
realizing like all of these different
musical influences that are from black
culture and it opened up the episode to
the like the beginning and the evolution
of American music and all of its racist
undertones and it was very very
eye-opening I if you only listen to one
episode I think that that episode was
super powerful um a little footnote
about 1619 that I heard back looking
feedback from the audience was that a
lot of people um and there was an
article written up about it that it's
actually a little factually incorrect
and when you were telling me about it
you actually said like you felt like
they were not 100% like rooted in fact
so yes I read because I saw some
comments that like you just need to look
into this because there are some factual
inaccuracies and so I guess there's this
conflict in the history community and a
bunch of these historians wrote a letter
to the New York Times asking them to um
correct some of these historical
inaccuracies and the historians who
wrote it they got a few signatures on
the letter and then other historians
spoke out and said I saw the letter they
asked me to sign it
um the guess there are some factual
inaccuracies uh but I did not sign the
letter because it aims to just like kind
of deal agendize the 16:19 project in
general and even though some of the
conclusions that are drawn um are not
necessarily what those historians would
have said or what historians have been
saying I do think that there's value in
hearing just different perspectives
especially when you're taught American
history through
the lens of you know old white guys the
entire time Jackie you said something to
me um just like in conversation last
week that like really struck a chord
with me and kind of um just like was
making me realize so many things and you
were like and and I had the same
experience like when you're taught
American history in high school like the
high school curriculum is like there was
racism we fixed it and now it's over and
I think that's why a lot of people have
like white people have like a hard time
understanding these like complex issues
because it's been ingrained as in us
since we were kids that like this is
over ya know the way American history is
sometimes start especially in like
social studies when I got it there's not
like so much time but um but it's taught
like okay there was slavery we abolished
it that left racism in the communities
it took a while but the civil rights
movement abolished the racism and now we
are good and like I mean that is just
given to you as fact it takes a lot of
undoing to realize like oh no we're not
good no and I think so much and we're
gonna talk about this like a little
later on so much of like what the racism
in this country is is subtle it's like a
micro regression which I just learned
what a micro aggression is and I feel
like that's not to blame but it's like a
almost a byproduct of being taught for
so long that like racism doesn't exist
yeah or like not to see color and that's
something that comes up in the movie
that we watch that I'm and yes looking
forward to recapping yeah I think and
when KJ APIs you know we'll talk about
it when we get to that's in yes
Oh something else that I wanted to recap
oh wait you know sorry
oh no I just I listened to code switch
and I got a bunch of episode
recommendations from the toasters
everyone recommended hood feminism which
I listened to and I loved and it just
really makes you think like about how
some of these like feminist movements
like the me to movement kind of like
misses all the nuances especially within
the black community and it's like the
black community is and women in the
black community like single mothers like
they're just not equal yet so it's like
you're forgetting about this entire
community
of women in this women's movement and it
was just really interesting to like you
you never think of those types of
details and nuances like when when
thinking about certain movements like
the me2 movement but the woman who came
on she like had coined the term hood
feminism and it was it was really good
but an episode that's someone not as
many people recommended to me but I
highly recommend was the episode on
adoption um and I was just like writing
these things down that I couldn't
believe like they were saying that in
certain like adoption agencies they
consider um black children to be like
less valuable and they will like
decrease the value and they had pig
listeners right in email and like
telling them about their experiences
being adopted from like Asia or
different countries and like being
brought into a white family and how one
they have like no sense of identity
because it's like they're like it was
they had the Southeast Asian guy he was
like well no one really thinks I'm Asian
but like I am Asian but like not but and
like I wasn't and it was like I wasn't
until I turn like 15 that I realized
like I wasn't quite like my parents so
you just don't think about those types
of identity issues within the adoption
community um and they just had like all
their listeners callin right in like
leave voicemails and it was just
interesting most of the episodes are
actually not the hosts they had they
bring in experts and they like let the
experts the authors the people who have
been adopted like do the majority of the
talking which I thought was really um
like really hits home the message um and
I really liked the adoption episode it
just made you think about things like
you would never think about if you're
not adopted oh wow oh man yeah next it
was good
okay thanks um also something that I've
been watching that I wish I had been
watching sooner is I started the Real
Housewives of Potomac um literally you
how do I tell you you told me you
completely told me and I'm so sorry that
I haven't been watching sooner scene 1
episode 1 like I'm just completely and
already here for it like I love Potomac
we need to move there I love the women
I'm in the middle of season 2 now um
such a good season oh it I feel like
that's what I remember you saying and
I'm not gonna lie I did a little bit of
research because I saw that Katie wasn't
back for season 2 and I was wondering
where she went
and I saw some of the stuff that I know
is gonna happen you know stuff that you
said happens with Michael but I tried to
not not read it um so I know that the
new season of Potomac is coming back
soon so we will be recapping that on
this show
I just absolutely I love the women I
love so many of them and I just I and I
also love it sometimes maybe it's
because it's like I was in season one
but it's like I love gizelle but a lot
of the times like I wasn't necessarily
on her side but like I still love her
you know and like even though Karen's
not my favorite so I think she was right
you know no no no that's the thing um
with Karen I struggle and me and TPG
like always go at it cuz he is a Karen
huger like number-one fan like bought
her perfume like sprayed me with it he's
her number-one fan and it's like she's
like this grand like Dom like she's in
charge of the social scene but like she
sometimes says and does things that are
just so like not right but he just like
rides or die for her and but that's how
I feel about gizelle yeah yeah I I feel
that and then you told me about gizelle
and Jamal and I'm very excited to get
there also season one they have a lot of
conversations about race as it relates
to them as it relates to race in America
and yes like we were listening to
educational things throughout the
weekend um but I think that season one
of Real Housewives of Potomac has that
conversation in a very entertaining way
and a way that's easy to understand and
I thoroughly enjoyed it and I look
forward to binge watching it throughout
the week yeah it took them like one
whenever there's a new housewife
franchise like I'm immediately just like
not like I remember even with Dallas
like I didn't watch like in full I was
just like not in the mood I'm like I
feel so happy with the housewives said I
do have but Potomac was this addition
that like once TV G really was the one
who got me on it and once I started it's
just so good and like at the reunions
they [ __ ] bring the glamour like
they're like Beverly Hills level like
they all just like match outfits they're
glam is so good their outfits are so
good like they take the job of
housewives very seriously and I compare
it to Dallas because they started
they've like similar amounts of seasons
and I feel like it just comes so much
easier for the Housewives of Potomac I
feel like they really
love the platform that they have and
they want to be role models for like you
know smart powerful black women and they
take that really seriously and like it
just comes naturally for them and they
are so glamorous and I just think it's
such a good show and I think that it's
like gonna be one of it like it's
delayed because of koban I think a lot
of the housewives franchises are delayed
um but I'm so excited for the new season
and I'm also really excited to see if
they're filming and if they talk about
like the current climate in the country
yeah definitely I'm excited to catch up
to where you are I remember when it
premiered and I remember the same thing
about cialis and I I dive into Dallas
because I was dating Zach and like he
was from there and I felt like it was an
easy way to get to know his city but I
actually felt the opposite of you now
that I was like happy with the house I
said I had it was like I'm tired of all
the housewives franchises that I already
watch like so I wasn't trying to walk
like watch even more but I would rather
watch Potomac right now than New York
definitely no it's it's it's just so
well done and they don't try too hard
like it's felt like Dallas they just
compare it to towels because they came
out like at similar times I just felt
like a lot of times in Dallas like they
just needed the show so badly that they
were just like forcing so many
storylines and I just feel like in
Potomac it's so natural like a lot of
the women have like really like long
deep-rooted friendships but they're not
like it just comes naturally for them
which is the best kind of franchise yes
I agree with that okay so um anything
else you want to recap before we get
into everything
um not recap because I just started hip
but I started the redheads book last
night Oh Maya Angelou that's our next
book for the redhead so it's a little
confusing but this week our episode will
drop where we recap code name Helene
which I'm in the middle of and it's
actually very very good and then we but
we announced that our book for next
month is going to be I Know Why the
Caged Bird Sings by Maya Angelou we're
all really excited to read it it's been
recommended by a lot of different people
and on a lot of different lists um about
how it's just um a very powerful
story about race and America and if you
are glad you're gonna be this yeah I
know
and if you're gonna buy it I read
there's like a full list of black owned
bookstores that you can and should
support if you can't I mean if you're
not gonna like buy it on Kindle um so
it's just like one extra step in
googling that I think most people might
not think about but if you're gonna buy
it feel free to support black on
bookstores definitely so yeah we have
like very good the book it's like funny
which is not necessarily what I was
expecting I'm so excited that you're
reading it they everything with us that
you're reading and I'm excited me people
have you on the next episode like to
share some thoughts moving maybe okay
now is it time I think so okay cool um
without further ado it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast cool cool cool
cool okay the first story I actually
felt was um kind of the perfect story
for the tone of today's episode and just
sort of getting into now you know some
well all celeb news some mindless some
not but John Legend discusses balancing
humorous content amidst the ongoing
protests during a panel for Sherman's
showcase executive producer John Legend
said it's important to keep creating
joyful content amid the important black
lives matter protests happening across
the country quote we still have to have
our sense of humor he said from the
couch on Saturday when the moderator
asked about conflicting feelings when
creating silly content right now quote
we still think there's a lot in the
world to talk about and make fun of and
there's a lot of joy we can share with
other people and I think it's important
to continue to share that joy that
laughter with intelligence and with an
eye to what's going on in the world but
people still need to laugh and enjoy
themselves he added I think it's
important that we show the fullness of
what it is to be black and human through
our art we are able to do that I mean I
love this and I feel like I had this
moment on black out Tuesday of last week
tik-tok was like highlighting black
cream
so my entire 4u page was like
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly black
creators from both like comedy to beauty
to like social justice and I just have
to say and I said this to you it was so
much better like I spent literally so
much of Tuesday on tick-tock like
listening and just watching all these
different types of content both funny
and like none serious and I just I
preferred it so much and then on
Wednesday like expected my my feed to be
like filled again and it was just back
to the normal like dumb stuff and I
don't know how to get back to Tuesday
because he's right liked it so much of
like the black experience is like
knowing all about all different facets
and like whether that includes comedy or
beauty or like black women businesses I
totally agree with so much better yeah
no I totally agree I feel like Instagram
has been a very powerful place to share
news and information but there have been
some people who are using it also to
bring levity to some of what's going on
the first person that comes to mind is
Justin Sylvester because he's just been
posting so much informational content he
did some podcast episodes he spoke with
the sheriff but he's still just like his
funny self and just sharing humor amidst
that this time and I think it's
important yeah it's obviously um
touch-and-go like not to make light of
what's going on but I agree with John
Legend like there there needs to be an
element of like levity sometimes yes I
agree with John Legend as well okay John
Legend and Chrissy Teigen I mean we
didn't do a show last week but if we did
we would have talked touch on it that
they donated $200,000 to like a bailout
fund for peaceful protesters who were
taken into custody which is just
fabulous yeah there are a lot of sub er
DS who are stepping up donating large
sums including Kanye West who launches a
college fund for George Floyd's daughter
Kanye West's on to college fund for the
six-year-old daughter of George Floyd
who was killed while in police custody
West set up a five to nine college
savings fund to cover tuition for Gianna
Ford his rep told CNN on Thursday the
rapper also donated two million dollars
to the families and legal team
supporting Floyd Ahmad our burry embryo
Taylor Wow I didn't know that Sam part
yeah that's a like I just feel like
obviously any form of donation is
amazing but to donate to someone's like
education is just so special and I feel
like Kim and Kanye are both like so
family focused and like their kids are
their whole lives and I feel like them
donating of course to the family and the
legal fund but also to Bria your
daughter's future is just so special so
special um and just like looking towards
the future and I think that was very
thoughtful and generous again yeah it's
very nice to see celebrities um stepping
up like that and also our next story is
a k-pop group BTS has donated 1 million
dollars to black lives matter BTS and
their management company big HIT
Entertainment donated 1 million dollars
to black lives matter earlier the sweet
variety reported on Saturday while the
kpop superstars didn't comment on the
donation on social media both black
lives matter and big hit confirm the
transfer black lives matter managing
director K Lee scales told variety quote
black people all over the world are in
pain at this moment from the trauma of
centuries of oppression we are moved by
the generosity of BTS and allies all
over the world who stand in solidarity
in the fight for black lives I mean this
is incredible obviously because a
million dollars is so much money but
also like they're so influential like
especially amongst a generation of like
young people whose minds are like you
know constants bun jizz you know they're
absorbing and I feel like of course the
money says a lot but I just think like
the actual like the message is so
powerful here given like what their
audience is who their audience is how
old their audience is and like how big
their audience is yes they are so
influential they are massive and I agree
that the money is fabulous but also them
taking the stance in this way is
important and wonderful yeah I think
it's and it makes it you know not just
like an American thing it makes it a
global thing because they're a global
group yes and there are global protests
and this is really like a worldwide
movement I'm sure that you saw the tweet
that was going around like
sort of yes saying how there has been
protests in 50 states every state in the
country and making this the biggest
civil rights movement in history which
is incredible and that's why like when
you said earlier like watching history
like this is definitely going to be in
textbooks you know yes definitely
okay switching gears a little bit cuz
Vanderpump rules
stars Stassi Schroeder and Kristen Doty
are apologizing to former co-star Faith
Stowers Vanderpump rules Stassi
Schroeder and Kristen Doty are breaking
their silence to offer apologies to
their former co-star fates towers on
Sunday they both posted lengthy
statements on Instagram to address an
incident with Stowers that she spoke
about recently during an Instagram live
chat with flora bama Shore star Candace
Rice lies love her faith who appeared on
seasons 4 & 6 of the Bravo series for
called a time when Stassi and Kristen
spotted a tabloid article about a black
woman wanted for theft and called the
police to pin the crimes on her quote
from faith there was this article on
Daily Mail where there was an
african-american lady it was a weird
photo so she looked very light-skinned
and had these different weird tattoos
they showcased her and I guess this
woman was robbing people and they called
the cops and said it was me uh Kristen
and Stassi this is like a true story I
heard this from actually Stassi during
an interview so Stassi had done a
podcast interview um detailing how
Kristen and Stassi called the police
because they believed that it was faith
in the images who was robbing people um
I mean this is terrible and I just feel
like not enough people talk about how
like we're just is for faith like she
had though honestly the worst experience
on that show and of course like you sign
up for reality show like you get again
his health into but it's like she just
like couldn't catch a break and they
just everyone was so like mean to her
for doing something that they've all
done like slept with each other's
boyfriends like she was just held to
like this different more impossible
standard and I just feel like she had a
terrible negative experience on the show
and I really like I feel for her yes and
doing something that they've all done
but also that like one of their friend
participated in as well and I feel like
faith wasn't just such a scapegoat for
them to not deal with like the real
problem of the infidelity that occurred
mm-hmm and I do feel like her experience
on the show was just truly unfair um
yeah and every like I mean this so
Stassi and Kristen I posted that you
know they're sorry for um for what they
did that it wasn't um like racially
motivated but they they see now how what
they did was calling the police right um
but they had said that you know at the
time they were just in defense of their
friend and you know all of the
infidelity that had gone on but I just
feel like you can't be so mad at one of
the people involved without being
equally mad at the other person the
person who owes you something right
where the person is your friend right
the president in a relationship yeah no
that's what I meant like I just feel
like faith had like no one gave her a
chance and she wasn't even given enough
air time to really like say her piece
and say her side of things and everyone
just kind of wrote her off from the
second she got there and I understand
why she's now speaking out about having
a bad experience and I feel like it
really just Harkins on like the lack of
diversity in Vanderpump rules like it's
been so glaringly obvious for so long
especially now like and it's not like
they have a small cast their cast there
was like 19 people at the Reunion yeah
and that one black person yes not one
yeah no there definitely needs to be
more diversity I I remember when his
faith was on season four though she was
good friends with Lala and I think um I
think she was dating Lisa's son Max yes
and like the three of them were like and
James was like their fourth friend and
like they were kind of a really fun crew
and and it would have been nice to
expand on that yeah I mean season four
was like too early like they were still
so focused on the original cast mates
but now so yeah the old the the original
cast mates are like so kind of jaded
that now they're focusing on like this
new generation
but this new generation doesn't include
any people of color right so I think
that I mean it's been time for a while
for a change in Vanderpump rules and
changing just like the cast um and I
think this just drives home that point
yeah especially um last week when the
reunion was airing it was I had
literally forgotten that it was on
because there was so much going on in
the world and when I did catch it they
it just felt it just felt so like out of
touch yeah like almost outdated when it
wasn't filmed that the too long ago
right so I think that you know I feel
really um like sad for faith I feel like
she just had a really negative
experience on the show and certain
people you know on reality shows and
have bad experiences but I feel like
hers was like really bad you know
because she was never given an
opportunity to like speak for herself
and it was just really like a lot of
talking about her yeah and she never got
to like be like hey this is my side of
the story so honestly I'm I'm happy that
she's kind of you know just going on
Instagram and telling her truth yeah I
agree
okay fifth and final story a little good
news for the class of 2020 because
YouTube's originals did their dear class
of 2020 all-star commencement yesterday
there was performance by Liz Oh Alicia
Keys former President Barack Obama
former First Lady Michelle Obama
Beyonce BTS Lady Gaga secretary Robert
Gates secretary Condoleezza Rice sundar
pichai and Malala were all there to wish
there well she's Taylor Swift was there
I know well they're all virtually
remotely etc um Tom chairs I minced
advice and are you vote for the
graduating class
Liz OHS performance did you see it of
her playing the flute to the chilly they
had a virtual Orchestra like you know
I'm 20 piece Orchestra like all at home
and they like put all the videos
together and liz' whenever she plays her
flute like it gives me life like it was
just so epic and so I got stellar it was
stellar like it was just so different
you know looks
these even regular graduations are just
so like corny sometimes oh sometimes
every time yeah so I feel like this was
actually kind of fabulous
yeah very fabulous I've been reading
some of the speeches that some of the
stars were sharing and I actually wanted
to pose a question to you if you could
give some advice to the graduating class
of 2020 what would you what would your
advice be hmm that's a good question do
you have an answer um I need to think
about it for a second but I feel like my
advice is always the same but maybe it
just needs to be tweaked a little bit
but I I feel I well you know if I'm just
like talking like you know just to what
I want I'm not like I'm the YouTube
thing where but if I'm just like being
real like I feel like a lot of people
get like really sad to graduate high
school or college and don't look forward
to the change that comes with it and I
just want to say like embrace it all um
you have so much ahead of you get
excited about it don't don't worry and I
just think my best life advice is just
to be yourself you know there's only one
you and everyone everyone looks forward
to meeting you oh that's sweet I think
my advice would be mm-hmm
like I feel like when I was in college
and in high school like if I was going
through something or like I had a pit
like it felt like the end of the world
and now it's like so irrelevant so I
would like try and encourage young
people to like have perspective you know
and and just if you're going through
something like it's gonna end you know
like it does yeah everything gets better
everything works out like don't let
whatever it is that you're going through
like define you yeah and you know what
it also is it like advice that sometimes
people give to me that it always like
just leave like eases my burden a little
bit when people are like just go easy on
yourself like don't be so hard on
yourself um like give yourself a break
cut like you're fabulous don't be don't
be so hard on yourself yeah I would also
give advice like don't worry about
having a million friends like just have
a few good friends yeah don't worry
about staying in touch with
everyone um it's unrealistic yeah it's
unrealistic you're gonna be really busy
and so um you just find your people also
if I would give some advice it's all
coming to me now I would just say like
always be grateful that you don't have
to do homework anymore like for me
graduating was this huge burden like I'm
sorry no college was this huge burden
like I was just never really good at
school like tests reading like I just
wasn't that type of student and for me
like graduation was this huge release
like knowing I'm never gonna have to do
homework again or like do it write an
essay or submit an assignment and like
lean into that because there's a lot of
you know trials and tribulations that
come with being an adult in the real
world like paying bills like there's a
lot of realness and that sucks but just
always keep in mind at least you're not
doing homework yeah and you know what
you will continue to have dreams that
you're doing homework or that you
haven't done yes um and those are kind
of annoying but at least like you get to
wake up and go on with your fabulous
life and I think my also have these
dreams like once a month I know my
advice would also be the world is your
oyster like take on this is your time
you know this is your time the other
thing and then I would also I would also
quote one of those classroom bulletin
boards what's right isn't always popular
and what's popular isn't always right I
would this is the one that's stuck with
me never stop asking why oh very
powerful who's actually those classroom
like quotes pretty profound deeply
profound and I don't think like our
young minds were able to process but I
think like looking at a sign every day
that said what's what's popular isn't
always right and what's right isn't
always popular like really struck a
chord with me ya know when they think
like on even just a very surface level
never stop asking why like for me that's
just meant like if something's not
making sense to me like in the class
like why how you know and now obviously
like later in life like it it means so
much more but I think just on a
technical level back in the day super
helpful yeah
I agree I'm glad that you agree okay so
those are the fast five stories and now
we're going to recap the toast movie of
the week which was the hate you give
before we do that is it is it okay if I
just like quickly grab the floor
really oh of course please today's
episode is brought to you by fiber if
you're a business owner chances are
you're reeling re-evaluating the way you
do business
establishing your online presence is no
longer optional it's necessary pivoting
quickly is hard enough but finding the
people to make it happen and feel like a
full-time job fibers freelancing
platform helps you find the right talent
to build your online presence
finding the right freelancer can be
frustrating and time-consuming not to
mention expensive there are so many
factors like how much will it cost how
can you be sure that they'll deliver so
fiber lets you hire freelancers with
proven track records and clear pricing
so you're never in the dark whether it's
building your first web site or
designing social graphics to celebrate
years of business fiber connects you
with the talent you need to keep moving
forward
eyeballs adapt and grow your business
with fiber they offer meaningful
resources to help SMBs transition and
tune into the new normal they connect
businesses with freelancers offering
hundreds of digital services like
graphic design copywriting web
programming film editing voiceover music
and more they have quality talent that
you can count on their sellers have
worked with influential brands like
Google Netflix MIT and PayPal and you
could review their seller ratings by
your feedback and more to select the
right freelancer based on your budget
find your talent today at Fiverr
SiGe are armed so it's two hours fiber
calm and you can receive 10% off your
first order with using code toast all
the digital services you need are in one
place that's 5mm fib er are.com code
toast
again that's fiber comm code toast
thank you fiber on to our toast movie of
the day which was the hey you give
starring a mantle a Stenberg who is
Queen Rue from Hunger Games yes um and
also a very star-studded cast in general
oh my god yes like I first of all I knew
nothing about the movie from plot to
cast which is my favorite way to watch a
movie like it's so rare that I haven't
seen a commercial or like read something
on Instagram like it was just I went
no idea what the movie was about and/or
who was in and I was just like so like
living every time someone turn around
Mike Regina oh he's so right common
Sarita carpenter
yeah but like it was just so like oh yes
I agree I actually had like I didn't
know what it was about but it was I mean
it was so good it was so powerful it was
so poignant for this week um in American
culture and I hope that you guys watched
along with us because it really just it
just drove home every single point but I
also there were so many powerful
conversations or things that were said
obviously something that really stuck
out to me was the thug life um acronym
like the hate you give little infants
[ __ ] everybody and I just kept thinking
about it like I kept thinking about it
as I fell asleep last night like it's so
[ __ ] true like what you put out there
comes back and like when you put out
hate it comes back and to be honest like
I felt really dumb because I wasn't
really understanding the whole the hate
you give thing little infants until the
spoiler alert ending scene when her
little brother picks up the gun and like
then it all just kind of like clicked
for me yeah but you see how it's thug
life yeah yeah for me there were two
really powerful moments I thought the
opening scene was incredibly powerful
especially given what's going on um
and how it like you know a lot of why
people might not realize like this is a
conversation that black parents have
with their children almost all the time
to be aware and like you know I for us
like we're taught like you know be
respectful but it's never like it's
gonna be a threat to your life and the
fact that like that's a common part of
growing up um black is just so crazy and
I thought they did an amazing job of
what I imagine those conversations are
like like they're very serious and kids
might not understand at the time but the
second they get pulled over it's like
ingrained in them and I just thought it
was like a really powerful scene and a
really powerful way to open up the movie
yeah yeah again I didn't know what it
was about but I was kind of
understanding what it might be about
based on that opening scene yes
definitely
and um
another really powerful thing was when
its array comes to the funeral and she
quotes I'm sorry I don't know who said
it but it's like there's no such thing
as an unarmed black man when like when
someone sees blackness as a weapon yes
that was just like everything yeah
no that that definitely sticks with you
um I felt like the scene when um star is
talking to her uncle who's the police
officer common yes yes and she's at his
house like talking about going before
the grand jury and they kind of get in
to the conversation of what would have
happened if you know it was a white man
in a suit in a Mercedes driving the car
and how the police officers reaction
might have been different I think really
just I like how the movie did a good job
of you know there's common is a good
police officer there are good cops you
know it's like but there is a racism
inherent in the police force that that
needs to be excavated I agree I thought
that scene was incredible I thought
there was just so many moments where
they like obviously the the movie had a
message but they kind of emulated in
different relationships like the
relationship with common or the
relationship with Sabrina carpenter they
emulated different conversations that
happen around the issue of police
brutality like always matter or you know
or with like black police officers I
just thought it did such a good job of
driving home a message while also
acknowledging other types of
conversations that are had around this
issue especially to Sabrina carpenter
which is like something as a teenager
like a privileged white teenager I
definitely related to like not being
able to see out of your own privilege
when you're in high school being like oh
it's sad for the police officers family
you know like I thought it was very very
well done yeah and then also what I
thought was well done is the
conversation that she has with her
boyfriend KJ Appa um and he was like I
don't see color and she was like if you
don't see my blackness you don't see you
don't see me yes and I feel like that's
something that at least for me like I've
always been like I don't see color but
now it's like you should
yeah yeah no and I thought that they did
all of this in in both subtle and very
explanatory ways and I just thought it
was an amazingly well done movie that it
talks about a has talked about a lot of
difficult conversations um but does a
very good job at it yeah um one last
thing that I wanted to say was hold on
it was just on the tip of my tongue oh
it was a via popping into the SAC behind
you no no it was um just give me one
second like I need to say it it's just
oh when you were talking about like
subtle things I thought it was really
like powerful how they didn't mention it
but at the end of the movie when she's
like finally feeling more comfortable
with like the two parts of her life she
starts to wear her hair naturally yes
and I just thought that was like like a
little detail that was very moving yes I
completely I completely agree it's a
great selection it was so great it was a
great selection I'm so glad it was our
first movie I'm so glad that we won me
I'm so glad we watched it this week it
came out in 2018 and I feel like it
literally could have come out tomorrow I
completely agree
yes I've also read the book it's based
on a book I've heard that the book is
incredible um and so I might I might
read that in a little bit yeah it's like
sad that it's so pertinent when it was
made two years ago like nothing has
changed yet but a powerful message
nonetheless yet and a powerful force for
change yeah so our movie for next week
would you like to tell the class yes
our movie for next week is hidden
figures which is one of my favorite
movies it's so important it has such a
great message it's a true story it's an
incredible story
Claudia hasn't seen it I'm so excited
for her to watch and I'm so excited for
me to watch it again
I like missed the boat when everyone was
watching it like during Oscar season and
then it like I was just didn't want to
be like the last one so I just never
watched it yeah that that does always
happen like it's either Oscar season or
or bust or bust um but it's Oscar season
here so we are going to recap it on
Friday so we have a few days to watch it
I like need to watch stuff the day
before because I have such a bad memory
like of course I want to watch the hate
you gave last
but I didn't watch it until last night
because I wanted to remember it yes me
too but then it's also like I was
watching it last night and I had wished
I watched it these before because they
just gave me a bunch of different
perspectives
um but ultimately I'm glad that I
watched it and yes we didn't need to be
top of mind for the show so that was a
great selection thank you to everyone
who recommended it also we didn't get um
because we didn't do a show last week we
didn't get an opportunity to highlight
black owned businesses which is what
we're gonna start doing every Friday so
we'll do it this Friday but if you
didn't catch our Instagram we
highlighted a fabulous company I'm
called Rebecca Allen they are a shoe
company and the whole concept of the
shoe is five shades of nude which jackie
and i were talking about and it like
didn't even occur to me like how
powerful that message is until you
explained it to me because you just
assumed knew that we were just we were
having this conversation about how we
totally didn't even realize like the
deep-rooted racism in the word nude in
the term nude because like nude is like
considered skin color color like a
pigment but there are so many different
shades of nude so why is nude like in
the crayon box of wise at this yes so I
just and then we started having another
conversation about band-aids yes you
were telling me it's the same thing how
it's like band-aids are meant to be like
skin tone even though like they don't
necessarily match my skin tone like it's
exactly sure but yeah flesh cut looks
like where are the brown and black
band-aids right they're supposed to
blend yeah it's just been eye-opening
little things like that so it was
Rebecca Allen I ordered my shoes on
Thursday by the way they came on
Saturday like it was crazy shipping and
they're so elegant I got the flats the
flats are like so elegant and fabulous
yes so we didn't it to do it on the show
but if you want to shop support black on
businesses it's called Rebecca Allen New
York they're available online and you
can shop there Instagram - which is
fabulous and the move and it's also if
you have any recommendations for black
on businesses that you feel passionate
about or you were a black-owned you are
black business owner reach out let us
know because we're always looking for
places to shop yes we definitely are
is that it I think that is all that she
wrote today okay well thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the Millennial morning show where we to
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasting me down so
that Spotify iTunes stitcher Public
Radio iHeartRadio Cass box all the
places whoever you listen to podcast
find us morning totally five star review
about a beautiful stunning
we love you guys so much we hope you
enjoyed today's episode and we will see
you tomorrow morning
bye bye see you